Karrie is with us in philadelphia hi
Carrie how are you hi hi Dave great how
are you better than I deserve what's up
I am my fiancee we just are planning our
wedding and we are trying to talk about
finances and everything get everything
squared away and figure out you know how
we're going to join our finances when we
get married I wonder if you have any
advice for that yep
the old-fashioned marriage vows now this
is after marriage okay this is not
before marriage you can start talking
about it you can even do some pretend
mock up budgets in pre marriage
counseling but until you're married I
wouldn't combine finances now once
you're married the day you're married I
would completely combine them the
old-fashioned marriage vows say for
better for worse in sickness and in
health
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledge
meaning we're both all-in those are the
marriages that work best and those are
the people that have the highest
probability of building wealth very few
people who get married and treat each
other like roommates
okay half of that mustard in the
refrigerator is mine you know and you
start all that crap where you're
splitting it I paid for the car and you
pay for the S and you paying for that
that's like having a roommate instead of
combining your finances when you combine
your finances it forces you to
communicate it forces you to dream
together it forces you to be afraid
together when times are bad it forces
you together and it's one of the most
healthy things you can do with money as
a matter of fact the marriage counselors
often say use a combining of a budget to
force communication in a marriage that's
struggling and we have experienced many
times over the 6 million people going
through Financial Peace University many
many many many many many thousands of
letters tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of letters over the years from
people saying fine
University saved our marriage because we
force you from a practical standpoint to
start budgeting together in one checking
account and that forces you to talk
about it if Sharon goes and buys a big
thing and I go and buy a big thing
there's not enough money in the account
checks are gonna be bouncing all over
town so we have to know together what's
in there and it forces us to stick to
our budget
it forces accountability of forces
communication and you know it's not your
student loan my student loan after
you're married it's our student loans
you're the one brought it but it's ours
and it's ours it's ours it's ours
everything's ours you change your
pronouns from out of the abundance of
the heart the mouth speaks and you
change your pronouns from yours and mine
oui oui
you become French it's ours it's oui and
that's the process I would use I'm just
telling you there's all kinds of data in
the research on the marriage side of the
coin and on the finance side of the coin
that that's the best process that causes
people to win now it's not to say that
one person is stronger than the other
one person is better than the other it's
not about me I'm telling you what to do
are you telling him what to do this is
about us learning to work together we
both have a vote submit yourselves one
to another and I mean I I have I have
made in the marketplace all of the money
that has come into our house for 32
years of our 37 year marriage and yet we
have an income we have an income it's
our household income she's got as much
say over it as I do that's how we chose
to run it and that has worked very very
well as opposed to I'm making oh my god
I guess I'll do what I want to do with
it and you're just gonna do whatever I
say you know yeah now that's toxic
garbage isn't it you don't wanna play
that nobody wants to play that so good
question I'm honored by you asking it
Thank You Kerry appreciate you joining
us